here's what you were doing on april 23
2020. oh right
i can't believe i forgot this
[Music]
we've quantified your digital footprint
so that you can see the impact you've
had on the internet
[Music]
this is what happens when you google
elijah wood oh boy about forty thousand
forty million four hundred thousand
results top stories the the toxic
avenger reboot rumored to be adding
elijah wood this is true although it was
a leak it wasn't an official
announcement
elijah wood american actor a series of
photos of me over the years born january
28 1981 yes 40 years um height five six
not a good day there are a lot of posts
saying you and daniel radcliffe look
alike do you see the resemblance i mean
in truth i do see the resemblance but i
also think we look very different
and it's that thing of like being a part
of
similar
fantasy sagas that i think is part of
the confusion i think had daniel been a
part of other films that didn't have a
sort of fantasy crossover perhaps we
would not be considered
to look alike as much as we do have you
ever seen a photograph of daniel
radcliffe and thought it was you or vice
versa definitely not no i've never been
confused
please read the following quotes google
has attributed to you these are very
funny and i was very young when i said
these things so apologies dream the
impossible because dreams do come true
[Music]
i think being different going against
the grain of society is the greatest
thing in the world i am not a star a
star is nothing more than a ball of gas
now i did say these things um so i
remember that last one specifically my
mom
she was so um
focused on humility and
bringing me up with humility that was
actually something that she would say
for me to say as a sort of answer to
that notion of like what's it like being
a star and so i remembered that really
specifically that's very sweet dream the
impossible because dreams do come true
sure
but that
that second quote just seems like
something that you would needle point
and put on a on a wall i i don't know
that's a little too or it would be in
that like motivational poster with the
dolphin jumping out of the
out of the water um right so people
always ask these questions can you
answer them is elijah wood a nice guy
i think i'm a nice guy
yeah
why did elijah would stop acting i
didn't
is elijah wood in a band um i get that
i'm not um but i do play records i play
other people's music from time to time
is zack woods
related to elijah woods
well i don't know about the woods but
zack wood is related to me yes
this is a google trend graph of your
names searched over the last 15 years
can you guess what these labeled points
are okay december 2006.
i don't know
wow happy feet and bobby released on the
same day that i don't remember that's
amazing july of
was that
the release of
the hobbit
that is
i'm really bad at this i'm gonna i'm
gonna tell you the rest of this is gonna
go horribly wrong i'm not great at dates
all right december 2012
that is the release of the hobbit for
sure yeah the first hobbit film that i
had a tiny little part in
april of 2020 i don't know why this is
spiking oh right i can't believe i
forgot this i was playing animal
crossing and i became really really keen
on the turnip market specifically but
there's this one girl on on twitter that
posted um that she was that her turnip
price was x amount and i just direct
messaged her and i was like hey would
you mind if i come to visit your island
and she let me onto her island and they
and she she and her friends were big
ryan johnson fans um specifically the
last jedi um and so when we we were
chatting on the island that came up and
i left the island by saying long live
ryan johnson and i believe ryan put that
on his banner on twitter for a brief
period of time
very funny all right
all right so speaking of important dates
does october 21st
2015 mean anything to you
2015.
see i told you i'm not great at dates
what what is october what happened all
right
it's the day marty mcfly traveled to the
future and back to the future part two
that's amazing
we broke down some of the data points
comparing you in the fictional 2015
and the real 2015. this is great okay
here you are in the fictional october
21st 2015. fave uh fashion choice green
colander hot and the fave hangout spot
would be the cafe 80s
okay and here you are in real life on
october 16th
2015 coming out of an airport
all right so stats age 34
screen credits up at that time 101.
that is crazy favorite fashion choice
i'm literally wearing the exact same
jeans so these are these have been
mainstays for me for a very long time so
these are apc raw denim jeans and then
favorite hangout spots
you know what i would say the alamo drop
tops which still remains a favorite spot
for consuming films maybe the best place
to consume foams in the world
all right let's switch over to imdb you
have a lot of acting credits i guess so
oh my god
you have a total of 115
acting credits that is staggering and
i've never truly have never counted um
so that is news to me okay of all your
acting roles you're best known for your
role as frodo baggins from the lord of
the rings trilogy
we watched the entire trilogy again and
added up all your screen time in the
theatrical versions of the lord of the
rings trilogy can you guess what it
roughly came to
two plus hours
two hours and three
film you were minutes
at any given time
so the way that it initially went is we
we primarily were focused on the first
film until we had a rainstorm that
washed away a number of sets we had some
flooding in in the south island a town
called queenstown our wet weather cover
was a scene from film three
when frodo is on the steps of kirith
uncle with sam and gollum and at that
point we'd not shot anything from the
third film we'd not shot anything with
gollum andy circus wasn't there so we
had someone standing in for andy circus
we didn't shoot the rest of the coverage
for that scene for a year just goes to
show how long we were in new zealand we
shot whatever we could for a day
didn't revisit that scene for an entire
year
okay also on imdb it says you've
produced 19 films so far
oh wow yeah
that's amazing okay so only five this is
here are the stats the percentage in
terms of the qualifications uh only 5.26
are classified as romance
26.32
are classified as comedies 36.8 percent
are classified as thrillers 52.63
are classified as horrors horrors horror
films it looks like you're a horror fan
uh what do you like about the genre i i
grew up watching horror films i was
never really scared by them i like that
anything's possible i think that's
something i love about genre cinema in
general is that the sort of rules of
filmmaking
don't necessarily apply there's really a
lot of room for experimentation it
elicits an emotional response
it gets a response out of you and i i
enjoy that and i suppose i'm a little
morbid i guess
all right let's talk about a few of the
films you produced
mandy oh man panos cosmatos uh
masterpiece uh color out of space and
then no man of god uh
that looks that poster looks like we're
about to arm wrestle it's not an arm
wrestling movie no man of god is
actually about ted bundy and his
relationship to bill hagmeyer the fbi
agent who met him
uh over the course of four years prior
to his execution colorado space is a is
an h.p lovecraft adaptation that we've
been trying to get made for a long time
it's something that we're deeply proud
of it was wonderful to work with nick
again
and then mandy in some ways mandy is a
perfect example of what exemplifies why
we wanted to start a company in the
first place and i think ultimately what
spectrevision is really truly all about
which is a filmmaker with a vision and
giving that filmmaker the space to do
whatever he or she wants to do um and
really playing with the genre it's weird
it gets classified as a horror movie
it's not a horror movie it's a revenge
movie so you're also in these popular
music videos on youtube tell us a little
bit about shooting each
okay so the first thing is paula abdul's
forever your girl music video directed
by david fincher before he started
making films first job i ever had i i'd
never worked on anything as an actor but
it was so exciting i got to meet paula
abdul she was so lovely yeah i have very
fond memories of that
okay beastie boys make some noise now
this is
man it was a gift a true honor and a
gift to be a part of that i i'll never
forget i i was talking to a
representative of mine who's like i
actually can get y'all on the phone he'd
like to explain it to you i'm like oh my
god i'm going to talk to adam yoke
and then he explained it and i laughed
my ass off and i was like that sounds
hilarious he's like you should read it
first and i read it and it was hilarious
and everybody felt the same way and it
was this this sense of like
we're so lucky we get to do this what an
incredible gift you know it was awesome
okay so we found we also found this late
night clip can you tell us the story
behind this appearance
so
this is an insane thing but there's and
i can't remember this gentleman's actual
name but i was in um moscow for press
partially for maniac weirdly enough
this guy has replicated the same format
of jimmy fallon so the show is the jimmy
fallon show but in russian and being on
it was it felt weirdly familiar but it
was also i think i had a translator in
my head so in my ear so he's speaking to
me in russian i'm speaking in english it
was very surreal but uh yeah so jimmy
fallon uh you have a counterpart in
russia
actually
one comment here
right elijah wood is a nice person and
there is some kind of sympathy for him
in my soul
some kind of simply
i love direct translation of languages
uh because the actual direct translation
is often like a strange bungled english
um but yeah there is some kind of
sympathy for him in my soul well thank
you
elijah is so cool so calm
pleasant does not interrupt he is just
cool and it started to kill and his blue
eyes can just drown
that's amazing
and
the end
what do you think
well that was quite the journey that we
just went on um that was super fun and i
feel like there's so much more that we
could have gotten into but i was i
really enjoyed that that was really a
blast